so i'll tell you what else i've been
watching recently i've been catching up
to re zero season two as well
me too this is like going back how many
episodes ago where we're just like
we're gonna get back to re zero here you
go fabulous we're getting we're getting
back to research
later the amount of memes that came out
one minute later don't
[ __ ] in the internet one minute is
nothing yeah man
can i just laugh at something okay why
is garfield a big orange cat
what's up with that i've never thought
about that before he literally turns
into a big orange cat have you watched
reserve season no i haven't so there's
one character called garfield
not garfield garfield garfield and
garfield oh yeah and he turns into a big
orange car a big
orange cat what the [ __ ] probably hates
mondays yeah i love lasagna i just i had
to like pause it when this like
okay spoiler uh zero uh when he just
starts murdering people
right this cat is just this [ __ ]
chunky garfield yeah just
murdering people and i was like wow now
i want to watch
this damn what timeline happened to
garfield right he died bro
it's on a monday probably i feel like
you should i mean i feel like you should
watch 3-0 season 2 because oh it's
amazing i think it's
[ __ ] amazing oh no i need to yeah
because i feel like
have you seen season one yeah of course
yeah so i i feel like
we go going back to our conversation
earlier season one set up the world
really really well oh perfectly
but then it i knew it had the potential
to go even further and i feel like re
zero season two
is definitely hitting that potential
yeah like one thing i've really liked
is how in like the first few episodes of
season two
there were just no deaths it was just
building up his character right right
right like
with what happened to subaru in the
first few episodes that was [ __ ]
genius
oh it's so good because it managed to
build up subaru's character
in a way that hadn't been like done
before and really just explore
who he is and why he acts the way he
does right yeah because
they built up this almost very childish
mindset that he had
that we often see in anime characters
especially in isikai yeah yeah exactly
and then they kind of just deconstructed
it in season two which yeah that was
amazing because it's like
i hate this [ __ ] incel and then
they're like here's the reason why
why he's going to change oh i respect
that
nice i like that yeah i've only i've
only heard the greatest thing because
season one
you know when you saw people who were
like dude i relate to subaru i'm like
what's wrong with you
the [ __ ] i think i mentioned this in
another room yeah but it's great because
it's basically they built that all up to
be like
okay now he's a shitty character and
we're going to teach him what he needs
to change and why why
those kind of behavior and i'm doing all
this for amelia is toxic
yeah as it would be yeah
yeah yeah and it's really interesting
cause i i didn't like it when i realized
what they were first doing but
i started to enjoy it so they're using
the the whole
reset thing right as a way to like
slowly build up this one kind of
thing that they're stuck in right now
yeah and i thought it was [ __ ]
annoying at first because i wanted them
to leave
the sanctuary yeah yeah and i really
like how they've just slowly been
building it up
yeah through the resets exactly and you
get a piece by piece and it because it
feels like almost like a murder mystery
where you're kind of getting little
information and it's just built it up
really well
i don't know i'm just really into it
right now and i'm so hyped where it goes
i have no no qualms it right now like
i'm i'm i'm actually way more into it
than i was season one
season one i very very very much enjoyed
actually i do have a
thing that i don't like uh where the
[ __ ] is ram i want my [ __ ] back bro
i get it she's just kind of gone but
that's how basic she is bro bro we
better get like a full [ __ ] scene
back i'ma say it i'm a saiyan
someone's gonna be like who's that
character talking about oh i'm gonna say
it
why would you still miss rem when this
perfect specimen
of of a beauty i can't get it i've
[Music]
because that was a meme that i saw in
the sonic fanbase base
it's always the sonic fan base where
they were like knuckles has four penis
heads and i was like
what and then apparently if you go into
wikipedia you look up like an actual
echidna like the animal
that's the knuckles is based off yeah
echidnas have four penis heads okay i
will admit she's a top-tier wifey she's
definitely pulling away she
broke she broke subaru down yeah right
and she's she like she when she got
introduced she just [ __ ]
i was like there were some three zero
girls that i liked and then there was
beatrice and then she just came along
and destroyed
everything literally it's literally that
meme with the car drifting
it's like going straight and journey
it's like
emilia
in one short episode i will admit it's
tempting
yeah but as a knight of ram my loyalties
cannot be swayed god damn it
you are not my queen i'm like i was
clowning earlier
people get serious about it
i do not betray my queen
if i don't trust men who sway their
simping
you're weak pick a s pick a wife and
simp
god wife is such a weak mind such a weak
mindset
you would be a terrible what do you even
like about rem what do you mean
what do you like about the question
she's like she's like cruelty free i'm
in a salad right right
like that's always the best [ __ ] part
no but the crunchiest part
that you can never you know you have to
worry about the amount of dressing on
them all right
rem rem never fails to just be there
right like rem she's there man you know
what i mean and she's always
rem came through she murdered him that's
hot first of all
all right and then and then she she kind
of you know she became
a woo you know and i i kind of opened
that
that's kind of hard okay i'm not gonna
lie i'm very struggling to remember
i just remember that she was loyal to
death and it was very endearing
how many times do we get waifus right
that put their heart on the line like
that and god's like well let me bring
out the notebook
let me bring out the massive list of
literally probably
but i feel like those waifus they they
wanted to
to get the result they wanted to be the
chosen one whereas rem
confessed knowing full well she was
never going to be picked and there's
something i can respect about that i
don't know about
that one man like i obviously haven't
watched enough haram anime because
that's like every other girl
[ __ ] yeah from the maine they say
that's what they they're like i know you
won't pick me but it's like in the back
of the head they don't want to be picked
now rem totally did it was just like
chad like i know you're not gonna pick
me but i [ __ ] love you
and that's okay king that's what i love
about ramen that's when
that single time when she confessed i'm
like i i don't know how many did she go
off on like an entire spiel of like how
she wants like a family and stuff and
like
do you think i [ __ ] remember that
it's just like i want three kids in a
cottage in the hills like
she what the [ __ ] i think i remember
something like that
she was pretty sick i mean it was
definitely like a flash forward or
something where she had kids with subaru
yeah
you can practice your pull-out game then
you know what i mean like it's
fine pull out and pray
[Laughter]
i mean that's fine if it fails you can
just reset
you're like you're like [ __ ] i hope the
checkpoint was over a month ago
it's going to be real awkward and she
comes back with like the results
you like you go back your checkpoint
it's like two weeks you're like [ __ ]
she's still pregnant you're like
[ __ ] go back we're [ __ ] awful people
i'm sure there's a [ __ ] dog i don't
know i can't remember i'll be honest
i can't i cannot remember i mean to me
like just does the king there's like all
the knights know why they fight for the
king they're like [ __ ] why are we
fighting i don't know i've
been doing it for like 10 years i guess
we should keep fighting yeah but that's
such a weak mindset yeah
that's a weak mindset bro a weak mindset
is swaying with the wind gone like you
do and you joey i haven't swayed yet i'm
i'm still from
the okay i already know you're gonna
sway i don't need a [ __ ]
i don't know what her canon age is i'll
have to i'll help you know okay
your honor that she was like this is the
problem right
let's say your waifu is beatrice or
[ __ ] shinobu yeah
you go into the movies right yeah you
turn up to the [ __ ] restaurant
uh table for two this is my waifu down
here
we're gonna sit and hold hands come come
to the table
no no no no no i can't stand the looks
i'm gonna get at that restaurant
when i was when i sit down with my
[ __ ] 10 year old at the table
and and we're playing footsies all right
here's the thing first of all she's 890
but second of all
waiter oh can she drink she's 800.
of course yeah no but here's the thing
is that like
at least my viewing of like my anime
waifus is that i
like them because they're not real do
you wanna you know
where we've gone we've gone full size
i like them like i don't want them to be
do you want a 10-page thesis on
on waifu theory i can give you a tempest
thesis on waifu philosophy okay right
now like
i don't want my anime waifu to be real
because
it's it's the whole it's going back to
the whole maid cafe thing where right
where
do you like kids jerry
it's the whole it's going back to the
whole maid cafe thing where it's like i
like it
because it's not real and the moment it
becomes real then you realize oh [ __ ]
this is not cool would you be happy with
someone if they [ __ ] murdered you
in a past life and you're like you know
what
you know we're cool now yeah you're
loyal to me now but you did [ __ ]
murder me that one time
did [ __ ] like chop off my legs and
[ __ ] beat me to death
like three times or something if it was
hot
that's not like some people's kink right
like it's like flat lining but not
coming back
right it's just like just actually just
just [ __ ]
dying like are we gonna find you in like
this
decrepit love hotel one day people are
gonna think i'm into some weird for i
assure you we're gonna walk up to your
[ __ ] like
we're gonna rock up to your dead body
you're just gonna have the biggest smile
on your face you're going to be like
died by like an
asphyxiation with like 10 stab wounds
and you got like
i unfortunately am i unfortunately i'm
pretty vanilla
uh but i love the idea of the kinks
that's what i don't understand about
people
the idea of these weird things that you
could do that i never want to do
but that's the thing right it's like
that's the thing you don't want it to be
real yeah
right but so you're okay with them not
being real that's that's how i see
you're okay with it with losing that
reminds me
it's such a weak mindset you're okay
with it not being real
you're okay with not growing